okay hi everyone
welcome to the last lecture of cs330
this quarter
okay so let's get into the content so
today
we're really going to talk about some of
the frontiers of
multi-task learning and metal learning
and talk about some of the things that
don't work very well or some of the
things are that are really on the fringe
of
the research that's being done
and some of the things that we could
potentially do to fix some of these
challenges
great there's also a question in the
chat um
a logistical question about whether we
can use late days on the final project
paper uh yes you can use late days on
your final project report
okay so uh and pretty clear in terms of
what we're going to talk about today
first we're going to talk about metal
learning for
addressing distribution shift
for
being able to handle
uh being able to quickly adapt a
distribution shift
by capturing equivariances and by
adapting with unlabeled data to
distribution shift
uh then we're going to talk about
multitask learning and meta-rl across
very distinct task distributions
and
what sets of tasks we might even train
on and some of the challenges that arise
when you do this
and then we'll talk about some of the
open challenges and open directions uh
that we haven't yet talked about in the
course
okay so
first let's talk about addressing
distribution shift and
first you might wonder why why should we
care about distribution shift in
particular
and uh for me the motivation to look at
distribution shift problems is that
there's this gap between
our current paradigm in which we study
machine learning research and our
current reality in which these
algorithms are actually being deployed
and for example in at least the realm of
machine learning research
the way that things typically work is we
assume that we have some data set
we train some model on a data set and
then we take that model and we evaluate
it
and then we report some numbers in our
research paper and we're done
however in reality
the world is constantly changing from
stock prices to
supply and demand over time
to robots exploring different parts of
the world
what the observations that machine
learning systems at any given point in
time
will change uh what they're seeing will
change and the way that they need to
make predictions will change as well
rather than just deploying a static
model uh that we just kind of we can
assume a static model will work as the
world is changing
so we need to be able to think about how
machine learning algorithms can handle
the fact that the world is changing
now you might wonder well machine
learning has been pretty successful in
industry how does industry cope with
this sort of change
uh
and
one perspective on this uh that i think
is quite useful is uh from chip huian
who actually works on machine learning
and production
and
she has said that machine learning
systems degrade really quickly because
of concept drift
and uh for online machine learning
systems you want to update them as fast
as humanly possible
so
with this in mind clearly the way that
most machine learning techniques are
being used
is not the way that many of these
research papers intended for them to be
used
so
what we'll talk about in the first part
of this lecture is how we might use
metal learning to very quickly to allow
models to very quickly adapt to
distribution shift
rather than kind of the current paradigm
in machine learning production where you
simply just
take your model and fine-tune it for
example on all the data that you've
collected so far and try to update them
as you get more and more data
okay
um so
now with this in mind we'll talk about
kind of two different forms of two
different ways to handle um distribution
shift via metal learning
and the first solution is that we'll
talk about is actually
motivated by the fact that
if you build in structure into your
models to solve
if you build and structure into your
models they'll be more robust to
distribution shift
uh for example if you build in the
structure of convolutions
then into your model then you're
effective effectively telling your model
that
it should be translationally equivariant
at least for that part of the function
and therefore if you then see data
that's translated then you can expect
the predictions to be also translated
for example or if you use things like
max pooling if you expect if you see
inputs that are translated then the
outputs won't change because it'll be
translation invariant
and so
this solution to distribution shift is
great when we know what the structure is
and how to build it in essentially if we
know how our distribution is going to
change like translations then we can
build in things like convolutions
but there are a lot of situations when
we don't know how the distribution is
going to change and we also don't know
um how to build it in
uh so
one question that we're gonna think
about uh
in this first part is can we discover
equivariant and invariant structure
via metal learning in a way that allows
us to build it into the model and hence
allow the model to generalize um
by kind of leveraging this sort of
equivalent and invariant structure
okay
um now one question you might ask is
well maybe metal learning algorithms
already do this
uh and so we can take the mammal
algorithm which learns initialization
runs a few steps of gradient descent to
get a new network
and one thing you might note is that
mammal can learn equivalent initial
features
so
this initial network right here
might exhibit features that are like
have certain variant structure like
translation like rotational equivalence
and so forth
or rotational invariants
but the gradient update
may
may kind of
get rid of that equivariant structure
equivalence may not be preserved
in that gradient update so even if it
learned initial features that are
equivariant the resulting network may
not actually preserve that structure
do you have a question
yes i want to ask if there are an
experimental
uh evidence that memo can learn
equivalent equivalent initial features
um
i don't know of any experimental
evidence i will show some experiments in
a few slides after i talk about one way
that we can fix this challenge uh and it
will actually show that mammal kind of
struggles to capture
equivariance at least in the sense of
this kind of second network uh or kind
of the resulting network having that
certain structure
i was asking can you explain why the
grading update might not preserve
equivariance so
i guess the
kind of what i mean by it not preserving
it is that like
the gradient update is um
like even if it learns a set of features
for example at this layer
that like has a certain that preserves
some sort of like equivalence property
if you update the entire network that's
going to update other parts of the
features
and if um
because like gradients especially
gradients with small amounts of data
have a lot of noise in them
uh it may be difficult for
mammal to arrange its initial parameters
in a way it allows it allows
this um this gradient update to
essentially can like preserve those
those features in such a way
i also think that the answer this
question should be a little bit more
clear as we talk about a solution for
solving this sort of uh this problem
okay so
in particular if we want to solve this
problem one thing that we could try to
do is decompose the weights of this
network
into an equivariant structure and some
corresponding parameters that are
disentangled from this equivalent
structure
and if we're able to decompose the
weights in this way
then what we could do
is only update the parameters in the
inner loop and retain the equivariance
and keep that fixed
in this kind of update process
okay so this may seem a bit a bit high
level and vague so let's try to actually
dig into how we might do something like
this
uh and to do this we can think about how
equivalences are represented in neural
networks
uh and in particular let's just look at
an example
so
if you take the example of a 1d
convolution where you have some filter
here that is kind of
slid across the input image or the input
x
then you get an output that looks like
this now
it turns out that you can actually
represent something like a 1d
convolution layer
using a fully connected layer
and what this looks like is
something like this where basically the
weights of the filter are repeated
in this weight matrix along the diagonal
of the weight matrix
and the remainder of the matrix is zero
and
it's not hard to see that the
basically
this weight matrix implements the same
exact function as the convolution here
uh by by seeing that basically when you
kind of do the uh do kind of take the
dot product of the the rows each of the
rows in the matrix by the vector x you
get the resulting output
so essentially you can view
things like 1d convolution as a certain
pattern in this matrix that tells you
how you should share parameters within
this fully connected matrix
okay
so
with that in mind how might we try to
decouple or decompose
the sharing pattern or which cover which
captures the equivariance and the
underlying parameters a b and c
what we can do is we can re-parameterize
this weight matrix w
and in particular re-parameterize it
into
first a vector of the underlying filter
parameters a b and c
and a matrix that basically just tells
you for each of the elements in this
weight matrix
which of these parameters or what
combination of these parameters
does that weight matrix value have
and so
basically this the kind of if you take
the matrix vector multiplication of the
sharing matrix and the underlying filter
parameters you get a vector of a bunch
of weights and then you can reshape that
vector to have the
matrix shown on the left here
so
we're going to call this u and this v
and
you
can capture symmetries by essentially
capturing how
underlying parameters should be repeated
or copied in your weight matrix
and v can capture the underlying shared
parameters
now
this
uh one thing that you can note a couple
things that you can note
first the sharing matrix doesn't need to
be binary
it can have real valued uh real valued
uh
entries
such that it's not just
picking one of these parameters it can
also like take half of a and half of b
for example
um and then the other thing is that this
you can apply this to fully connected
layers
but you could also apply this to things
like convolution layers the kind of the
output of taking u times v is just a
vector of parameters and that vector
parameters could correspond to something
that you eventually reshape into a fully
connected weight matrix or could be
something that you reshape into like a
com a set of convolution filters for
example
and uh interestingly it turns out that
for this particular re-parametrization
of the weight matrix
you can show that
theoretically this can directly
represent
a decoupled equivalent sharing pattern
and filter parameters
and you can show this for all group
convolutions with finite groups
i don't want to get too much into kind
of the group theory side of things but
the kind of gist of this is that it
could represent a number of kinds of
equivariances not just things like 2d
convolutions and 1d convolutions it can
also represent rotational certain forms
of rotational equivariance reflection
permutation equivariance
among another among um a kind of a wide
variety of
equivariances
although not all equivariances so
there's also
infinite groups equivalences
that this cannot cover
okay
um but beyond the theory kind of the key
idea is that we're going to
reparametrize this weight matrix w to
have one component that can capture
symmetries and one component that can
capture the underlying shared parameters
now once we have these re-parametrized
weight matrices
what we can do
is in the inner loop we'll only update
the vector v which are the underlying
parameters and keep the equivariance
fixed
this is such that when we run gradient
descent we can kind of preserve the
equivariance structure or the weight
sharing patterns that are captured by
you and only up to update the parameters
and then in the outer loop we're going
to learn both u
and v
this allows us to essentially try to
extract
or discover the equivariances that are
present
in a set of tasks
so kind of visually what this looks like
is
if your if this kind of red gradient is
showing your inner loop loss
the the inner loop loss in mammal
then when you compute this inner loop
loss you're only going to apply it to v
this right here maybe i should pick a
different color um this is kind of
the pre-update where you're computing
the gradient update
after you've computed the gradient
update
right here
you get the post update
model right here
and this uh this post update model only
has the underlying parameters that have
been updated
uh and then you'll evaluate this model
this is like
this is your your train set this is your
test set for these tasks
now one important assumption here is
that
there are some symmetries that are
shared by all of the tasks
and
if all the tasks share
uh share some kind of fixed set of
symmetries and the goal is for this
procedure to be able to extract those
symmetries
in the matrix u
okay um so we refer to this approach as
metal learning symmetries by
reparameterization or msr are there any
questions on the method before i get to
some of the experiments
okay so
yeah
uh why are we updating you with what
yeah so we're not updating you in the
inner loop because we want to be able to
preserve
like basically to extract equivariance
from a set of tasks
and preserve that equivalence when we're
when we're
trying to learn a new task
and in particular if we have that
equivariant structure and that weight
sharing pattern fixed when we're
learning a new task then we should be
able to generalize more readily from a
small amount of data because it the
network itself is kind of capturing
things like rotational equivariance for
example and then should be able to
generalize two rotated images okay thank
you
all right um so
when learning the aqua variance matrix
do we like impose any constraint on it
or like we just let it learn it by
itself
because like i see the example um you
sort of have like
some sort of structure that makes it uh
preserve active variants right
yeah i mean in general it makes a lot of
sense i think to to impose some sort of
structure on the matrix
uh either in a hard way or in a soft way
through like a regularization
um
the
in this work uh i guess one thing that
we did with you is because u is a quite
a large matrix we experimented with
different ways to reap to um
different ways to represent you for
example using a chronicler factorization
or a low rank factorization so that it
has fewer overall parameters um but it's
likely that there's actually a lot more
interesting things that you could do
there to try to impose certain kinds of
regularizations on you to encourage it
to discover equivariances and and not
kind of capture other kinds of structure
okay thank you
yeah everybody's asking can you also
talk a bit about what we mean by
equivariance and how do we measure it so
um if you want to be equivariant say you
have
um some
some function
f of x that produces y
then
being
maybe then you have this kind of other
function that you want to be equivalent
to or that you want your function to be
equivalent to maybe this is function g
maybe this is something that translates
the image for example
um
what
what equivariance kind of means is that
when you
when you basically apply
f
to
something that's been transformed
by g
then kind of this will give you an
output that corresponds
to g of y
so it's basically transformed in the
same way
and then
invariance means that when you transform
the input in some way the function still
outputs the same thing it's invariant to
those transformations
yeah my question is regarding to the
structure of you so for the example
that's presented here it seems that you
can be like quite sparse in nature so
can we leverage that structure
to like maybe minimize the parameters of
you as you said like you have like many
parameters yeah so encouraging something
like sparsity with like an l1
regularization could make a lot of sense
um
we didn't we haven't experimented with
that
ourselves but i i think that it could
make a lot of sense in um in future work
and this work is very very recent as you
as you might have seen so
uh
there is it's kind of
on the frontier and fringes of research
thank you
okay so on the experiment side we
looked at a few different things uh the
first question is
can we recover
convolutions from translationally
equivariant data
and to study this question we set up a
fairly like a synthetic experiment
or experiment with synthetic data where
we just took a random
convolution functions random 1d
convolution functions
and metal learned across
those set of 1d convolution functions
where each function corresponds to a
different task
and what we wanted to see is if we took
this method and used a fully connected
layer a fully connected network instead
of a convolution network if it could
recover the same performance as giving
the network the convolutions itself
and so in particular if we take
um
if we kind of
take these convolution functions and
measure the mean squared error on held
out tasks what we see is that
mammal with fully connected
mammal with a fully connected network
and mammal with a locally connected
network
both struggle to get good performance uh
and this is kind of what i was talking
about before where it isn't able to
capture this sort of equivalent
structure it may be destroyed in that
gradient update
whereas mammal with the convolution
network can obviously do quite well
because
the data is translationally equivariant
and interestingly this approach
building on top of a fully connected
network is also able to do about as well
as mammal with a convolutional network
suggesting that it's able to kind of
recover the structure from the data and
preserve that
in the
gradient update
and the other cool thing that you can
look at is you can look at the
matrix that's recovered by msr and you
see a matrix matrix that looks like this
that looks basically exactly
like the kind of
the abc repeated over the diagonal of
the matrix showing that it did indeed
recover 1d convolutions
now next we can ask uh
can we recover something better than
convolutions in situations where our
data isn't perfectly translationally
equivariant
so if we have data with partial
translation symmetry for example
um
that's when
that's shown in the results here when k
equals two and k equals five
and in particular what i mean by k here
is k is the rank of a locally connected
layer and if the rank is one then
there's just one filter that's copied
across copied for all of the
kind of locally connected parts of the
network if k is two that means there's
two filters and if k is five that means
there's five filters
and what we see here is that uh mammal
with convolutions isn't able to capture
this well because
it
because it's trying to encode too strong
of a symmetry it's trying to encode full
translation symmetry whereas msr is able
to do well across the board because it's
able to recover
the symmetries that are present in the
data
um you could also look at data with
other forms of symmetries like rotation
and reflection um and in this case we
also see that msr is able to effectively
extract that some image symmetry to do a
lot better than mammal just with
convolutions
by actually extracting the rotation and
the reflection symmetry
do you have a question
uh yes so is
is these experiments down in the future
resume or
yeah these are all done in the future
regime and the
uh this is showing performance mean
squared error performance on held out
tasks
so if you have enough data to expect the
memo with fully connected will
be able to learn this task
yeah so if you have enough data on
of the held out test task then we would
expect
um we'd expect all these methods to be
able to do well because um
because there is basically enough data
to learn that structure from scratch on
the test task
uh you would probably need considerably
more data than than the fuchsia regime
because basically like a convolution
layer has like significantly fewer
underlying parameters than an entire
fully connected matrix
cool that's a good question
okay and then i guess the one thing that
i didn't mention here is in this last
experiment we actually applied msr on
top of a convolution uh a convolutional
function or a convolutional layer
okay um and then lastly i'll also
mention uh an experiment
where instead of trying to recover
uh symmetries from
the synthetic data we're looking at
learning symmetries from augmented data
and in particular you can run a meta
training process that looks something
like this
that's basically the same as your
standard meta training
process
but instead of
just passing the train and vowel set of
each task as normal
you augment the validation set
and by augmentation here i mean things
like random crops random scaling
lighting variation and so forth
and then essentially train the model to
be able to generalize
to this sort of augmented data
from an unaugmented training set
so you'll basically change your your
trained test splits to look to have a
normal train split an augmented valve
split and then
run your standard
metatrading algorithm
with this split
and essentially what this is trying to
accomplish is baking data augmentation
into the architecture or update role of
your meta learner
cool and then what we find is that uh
if you compare if you first compare msr
with mammal
you get kind of performance gains across
the board by
by nature of being able to capture these
equivalences from the augmentation into
the training process
it also outperforms almost no inner loop
which just corresponds to mammal just on
just on adapting the last layer
uh which is nice because if you only
adapt the last layer then that actually
allows mammal to capture equivalent
features but only update the um the
features on top the the weights on top
of that
uh and is also able to perform
uh slightly better or comparably to
prototypical networks
in the omniglot setting uh but
significantly better on mini imagenet
where things are a bit more challenging
okay so
uh
kind of one takeaway that msr provides
is that it it really gives a framework
for understanding the interplay of
features and structure in meta learning
and allows the network to
fix the structure when you're trying to
learn and only learn
uh
features that are specific to the task
and this this kind of
this idea of fixing some things and
training other things may provide uh
kind of other
may allow us to kind of learn and
capture things other than equivariances
for example
okay so
capturing equivariances is one way that
may allow you to generalize better from
a small amount of data
um
now i'm going to talk a bit about
adapting to distribution shift in the
setting where you don't have any labeled
data
and so
to start off
this part
it's useful to think about what sort of
distribution shift we're going to be
adapting to
so in the previous section we were
adapting to distribution shift
where
the things that were kind of changing
were kind of translations or rotations
or other sorts of transformations on the
data
in this work
or in this kind of part of the lecture
we'll talk about
just a kind of distribution shift that's
a bit more broad than those kinds of
transformations
uh in particular we're going to focus on
what's called group shift
we're going to assume that there's a
categorical group variable z
this may correspond to different users
or different locations or different
times of day
and this sort of information can
typically be derived from
metadata
in your data set
and then we're going to assume that the
training data comes from
this distribution where there's this
distribution over the underlying group
and then your data distribution actually
depends on that underlying group
and that your test data corresponds to
this distribution where
p of x y given z is identical but the
distribution over this underlying group
variable has changed
and this can capture
label shift it can also capture most
forms of covariate shift as well
okay and then uh our goal will be to try
to be able to adapt to this sort of
group shift
with only unlabeled data with basically
only x and without having any access to
y
from
this part of the test data
um yeah this sort of study also captures
problems like federated learning where
you want to adapt to different users or
different devices
now it's worth understanding what sort
of approaches have been used for
distribution shift in the past and one
very popular approach for handling group
shift is called group distributionally
robust optimization
the way that this class of approaches
works is that you form an adversarial
distribution q of z
over your group variable
and then basically optimize for the
worst case group
during trading
and so you're essentially trying to
prepare for
the worst kind of group that you're
going to see at test time such that when
things shift
you'll still be able to perform
well
and so basically you form this
adversarial distribution and you're
going to be minimizing the loss over
this worst case c
the benefit of group dro is that it can
enable robust solutions it's also less
pessimistic than adversarial robustness
where you're trying to consider
adversarial robustness is considering
really a much broader set of shifts
where it's not just shifts in this
underlying group variable
the downside of group dro is that it
often sacrifices
average performance
by try in in the process of trying to be
robust it tends to be somewhat
pessimistic about what's going to happen
in the future
and so what we're going to try to do
here is to adapt a distribution shift or
to be able to handle distribution shift
we're going to try to use metal learning
in a way that allows us to adapt to
distribution shift rather than simply
trying to be robust to distribution
shift
okay
and so in particular what's going to
happen at test time is you assume that
you have unlabeled data from your test
sub-distribution
for example like a new user a different
time of day a new place
one example
that you can consider here is a
handwriting recognition scenario where
you're given data from a new user of
kind of handwriting data of just the
inputs
and you want to be able to use these
inputs to better recognize the
handwriting of this user
so you take this unlabeled data you
adapt your model using this unlabeled
data and also infer the labels for all
of the data points simultaneously
and
one of the assumptions that this is
introducing is that the test inputs from
one group are all available in a batch
at test time or at least in a streaming
setting where you're seeing things like
one at a time all from a single group
and you can kind of store the data that
you've seen so far from that group to
allow you to adapt to that on the fly
okay
now one way that this is different from
things like fine tuning and metal
learning is that this data is completely
unlabeled you're you're only adapting to
unlabeled data you don't get any labels
from this part of from this task or from
this part of the distribution
okay so we'll refer to this as adaptive
risk minimization
and the way that it works is you
basically just construct different
sub-distributions of your training data
this will correspond to different tasks
and then you train for fast adaptation
with unlabeled data to these different
tasks or to these different sub
distributions
where different sub distributions
correspond to like different users
different times of day and so forth
now
you might ask well how do we actually go
about adapting with unlabeled data
a lot of the algorithms that we've
talked about in the course may not make
that easy
so there's two things that we could do
one thing that we could use to use
mammal
but instead of using kind of mammal with
a standard loss function in the inner
loop which we can't do because we don't
have labels to compute that loss
function
we're going to actually learn a loss
function such that when we adapt with
that loss function on this unlabeled
data our parameters
are can effectively
solve the task or solve the group
and so what this looks like is we have
some initial parameters
some loss function network parameters
and our examples we run gradient descent
on
our learned loss function where this
loss function has some parameters
phi and then we
the result of gradient descent is we get
a model with new parameters data prime
and we run our examples through those
updated parameters
and then another way we could adopt with
unlabeled data is something more like a
black box approach where we take some
neural network this neural network takes
us and put the unlabeled examples
and this is fed into um this is this
gives you some context
and you could essentially view this as
like kind of
this is d train
um
for the test um
this is
x test
and this is just basically a neural
network that takes as input the training
data and the test input just like a
black box approach the main difference
is that d train only consists of
unlabeled examples and doesn't have any
labels
yeah so it's asking can you explain what
is unlabeled here and what is labeled so
the these examples here
are unlabeled so like the examples that
you get from a new user are unlabeled
and then you're using these unlabeled
examples to adapt to that users the way
that they write
and then you're also
you pick one of these examples in your
train set this is also fed in here and
you're predicting the corresponding
label
you assume that you have labels for
training this meta learner at
kind of during meta training but you
don't have those labels to adapt at meta
test time
does that answer your question
what are some parameters when you say
we're learning the loss function is it
parametrized
yeah so the loss function is has
parameters itself and this is
essentially something that takes as
input
the prediction from
from theta
and kind of outputs a scalar value and
then you take the gradient of that
scalar value and back propagate that
into the parameters of the network theta
okay
cool and then in the simplest setting
this um
this context c in this network can
actually just correspond to batch storm
statistics where you're basically just
computing
about storm statistics using when you
pass in these unlabeled examples into
your network
um and this kind of essentially provides
a way to adapt the network to the sound
label data or to essentially condition
the network on that data
okay so
now how does this kind of meta learning
with unlabeled adaptation actually look
like
um
experimentally we compared to empirical
risk minimization or just like standard
training
um we also compared to the distribu
group distributional robustness that i
mentioned before
and then lastly we can also compare to
empirical risk minimization but
upweight the groups to the uniform
distribution and this allows you to
essentially
like if some of the groups are
underrepresented then uploading them to
the uniform distribution will allow you
to kind of do better on groups that are
underrepresented
uh then we'll also evaluate arm
and we'll specifically look at kind of
three different versions of arm one is
adapting with a context variable this is
somewhat similar to like conditional
neural processes which is just a certain
black box architecture
one is adapting using the batch form
statistics which is also kind of an
example of a black box architecture but
is only
the the kind of the way that it's
conditioning on the data is through the
batch format statistics
and then this corresponds to kind of
mammal with a learned loss function
okay um so we can look at one setting is
the federated extended mnist data set
and what this corresponds to is you want
to be able to
predict the like be able to recognize
handwriting of different users
and
by extended mnist it actually contains
not just numbers but also
um
also like the english alphabet
okay um and then we'll actually also
compare to kind of a federated learning
a recent federated learning method here
as well
uh and what we see is
the
um
first you kind of see a five percent
improvement in average accuracy
from being able to adapt with unlabeled
data acro like kind of
you take the best one of these around
eighty percent this is about 85 percent
and then what wc means is that we kind
of see a 10 improvement in worst case
accuracy
and in particular what worst case
accuracy is looking at is it's looking
at your accuracy on the user in which
you did the worst
and this is a useful metric because
you want your users
you generally want your users to have a
similar experience and if you have some
users that you're doing terribly on then
they probably um they might quit the
platform or whatever or they might
not be very happy um or it's kind of
unfair to that user because the model
isn't doing very well
and this worst case metric gives you a
sense of kind of how fair things are for
the users and how well you're you're
able to treat your um
treat kind of minority users and so
forth
um and so this 10 improvement is pretty
substantial
yeah and then it's asking is bm learned
or just calculated from the unlabeled
data so
the the statistics are just calculated
from the unlabeled data the critical
thing though is that and the thing that
makes this different from just like
standard neural network training with
patch normalization
is that
you're actually training it such that
like when it gets a batch of data from
um from a certain group
those batch term statistics allow it to
uh adapts to that part of the
distribution
and so essentially what we're doing here
is when you sample batches during
training you're actually sampling the
batches to be correlated from a certain
part of the distribution and then you're
also assuming that at test time you're
given a user and you're given a batch of
data from a single user rather than a
batch of data from
from uh
from like all users
and pointing out it seems like it
performs as well as learn cml or learn
loss
[Music]
so
you're kind of still metal earning it
such that when these bat storm
statistics are computed across the
um computer across the examples it does
well so you still kind of have this
metatrading process
i guess
the big thing that's different is that
like in cml
it's actually learning what this context
should be whereas in batchform
with batch form adaptation that context
just corresponds to an average set of
an average set of activations and the
variance of those activations
um
by manipulating this network it can
actually kind of choose what it wants
its activations to be such that those
statistics are informative of what part
of the distribution is in
yeah and then asking why do we need cml
and learn loss which is more complicated
uh
the i guess
i think there
may be some settings where cml
uh performs
better
and
[Music]
i guess i there there were so like one
at least one example in the paper where
bn was not the best performing method um
but in general it does seem like this
this kind of approach is the simplest
and also works quite well so it's
probably what i would recommend
okay and then we can also look at a
qualitative example so
if you were given this image right here
it's ambiguous whether this is like a 2
or an a
and
also actually in this data set
in general numbers are kind of
overrepresented compared to characters
and if you just train erm
on the entire data set it tells you that
it thinks it's a two
if you give the model just these two
examples from that test user then
you think that it's kind of also a tube
because this doesn't tell you that much
but if you give
the metal learner kind of all of these
examples
then you could actually see examples
like this for example
suggest that the user writes twos like
this
and
or or like this for example and not like
this
and that allows you to actually to adapt
your classifier of
to this particular user
and by kind of adapting with these 50
examples it can successfully classify
this as an a
okay
and then kind of one more experiment
that's a little bit more
kind of larger scale is you can look at
c4c and tiny image.c these correspond to
basically a variety of different kinds
of corruptions to the cfar data set and
the tiny imagenet dataset
and the goal here is to adapt to new
image corruptions after kind of training
on different other forms of image
corruptions
um so we train on 56 corruptions and
then test on 22 disjoint corruptions
that weren't seen during training
and what we see is that we see a three
to ten percent improvement in average
accuracy so about three percent
improvement on tiny image.c and then
about a 10 improvement on c410c
and then in worst case accuracy we
actually see a much larger improvement
we see an eight to twenty one percent
improvement there which is pretty
substantial
i was asking what loss does cml learn in
this case
so the block box methods aren't learning
any loss
they are kind of adapting by just
feeding the data into the network
okay
so
so the takeaways from this part of the
lecture are first kind of preliminary
evidence that metal learning can capture
equivariances by reparametrizing the
weight matrices
and second by allowing
we could allow adaptation and
fine-tuning without any labeled target
data
by actually training for this sort of
adaptive risk
so these are the two promising
approaches for addressing distribution
shift and being able to very quickly
adapt when the distribution is changing
okay
um
cool and then
the second part of what i'd like to talk
about is what does it take to run
multitask and meta rl across distinct
tasks
so
first
um when thinking about really like
distinct task distributions
one thing that i think is useful to
think about is like have we accomplished
our goal of making like policy
adaptation for example very fast and
effective can we now like with the med
learning techniques that we've talked
about in class can we now enable a robot
for example to learn a completely new
task really quickly after learning a
wide variety of previous tasks
and i would argue that like a lot of the
examples that we've seen so far in class
are allow the policy to adapt
quickly to small variations on what it's
seen before
but
not really kind of allowing policies to
adapt to completely new tasks that we
haven't seen before
and if we wanted to adapt to entirely
new tasks one of the challenges is that
we need our metatrading task
distribution and our meta testing task
distribution
to be like roughly the same
and if we need our task distributions to
be roughly the same and we want to adapt
to entirely like distinctly
qualitatively new tasks then we're going
to need a very broad task distribution
such that uh
such that when we kind of train on this
broad task distribution
something something that's like a
distinctly new task still kind of
generally falls under that broad task
distribution
um so you need a broad distributions of
tasks for metatrading we also need this
distribution to not be completely sparse
such that we can at least expect
generalization within this broader
distribution
uh if you think about in the context of
of meta-rl um
where we get kind of a set of a broad
distribution of tasks
uh there are a few options so there's
things like open ai gym which have
different uh
different uh continuous control problems
there's also the atari learning
environment and there's this kind of
surreal benchmark of different
robot tasks
however
these different benchmarks aren't
particularly well suited for metal
learning so
things like atari for example don't have
a lot of common shared structure between
them they're quite distinct uh i think
you also mentioned this on monday the
same thing with kind of open eye gym
these are kind of very sparse and
distinct tasks
that wouldn't necessarily allow
generalization to a completely new agent
uh and
for this last paper
uh there's only like around six tasks i
think so
we won't necessarily expect the ability
to generalize to a new task or be able
to quickly adapt to a new task when only
meta training on six tasks
uh so with this in mind we wanted to
create a benchmark that'll kind of
captures
a large number of qualitatively distinct
tasks um that have shape reward
functions and success metrics
uh and critically have some sort of
shared structure
such that we can potentially expect
generalization across season across
these environments and tasks
and so the way that we did this is we
tried to unify
a state and action space across all of
the tasks
uh and this was the the result of this
effort
um so this is the meta world benchmark
it has 50 different tasks i mean it
basically satisfies each of these does
iterata
uh with the hope of enabling or allowing
us to study whether meta-oral algorithms
can leverage these very broad and
distinct task distributions to
generalize to completely new tasks that
you want the robot to do
and
so now if you run metal learning on
these algorithms
metal learning algorithms seem to
struggle so if you evaluate them on held
out meta test tasks their success rate
is only around like 20 to 30
and it turns out that
even like they're kind of struggling on
meta test time but they're also
struggling on the meta training tasks
so this suggests that it's having
trouble kind of even learning to learn
the set of tasks that it's given during
metatrading
and
so further this kind of suggestible
maybe we should just look at multi-task
learning if we can't learn
the the set of tasks themselves then
meta learning may also be quite
difficult
so if you kind of evaluate multi-task rl
algorithms on these you also see that
these algorithms are are struggling to
get
uh like even above like 35 percent for
example
okay so uh why the poor results um
first you maybe it's an exploration
challenge but we made it such that all
the tasks are individually solvable
maybe it's a data scarcity challenge uh
however all the methods were given a
budget with plenty of samples
it may be kind of a limited model
capacity issue
but in this case all the methods were
given plenty of model capacity
and it turns out that actually just
training
models independently on all the tasks
actually leads to a better success rate
than if you try to train with soft actor
critic
on a single model and policy
on all the tasks
so this suggests that it seems like that
there must be kind of an optimization
challenge when you try to train across
all of these tasks by nature of the fact
that kind of independent training does
better than if you try to share weights
i have a quick question
i was just wondering because there's a
link to my project how do you measure
model capacity because we haven't
studied the context of overfitting and
meta learning we claim that these things
won't work fit so how do you measure
model capacity and also how do you
measure plenty of samples
yeah i guess um
i think that it's hard to measure these
sorts of things in this case for model
capacity we tried making the models
bigger and it didn't help um so that
suggests to us that they had plenty of
capacity and in terms of data scarcity
what we see here is that even kind of a
multi-task train even a multi-task
policy levels off and if even if you
give it kind of more environment steps
it doesn't continue to improve
okay
okay i i i'm still confused about why
uh
the the task can be learned individually
better than
uh learning with memo also speaking of
memo how
we have the inner loop which i think is
almost
exactly the same as learning from
scratch using
session self
after printing method
yeah so in this case uh soft vector
critic is just that this sac corresponds
to a
um a policy at a critic that is
conditioned on the task id
and trained to perform all of the tasks
so this doesn't correspond to mammal
although i showed mammal results on the
previous slide
in principle with mammal you can
if at test time you kind of fine-tuned
with enough samples then it would like
be able to do as well as independent
when we looked at that performance that
was with kind of a fixed budget
of samples at meta test time
and here what i mean by plenty of
samples is that's kind of the number of
samples that you get
during meta training or during
multi-task training uh
i speak of the samples you mean
the steps
oh by samples yeah i mean the kind of
number of environment steps or the
number of episodes oh i said thank you
okay
um
so given this optimization challenge i
guess the first takeaway here is that it
does seem like
training on diverse and distinct tasks
shouldn't necessarily be taken for
granted it seems like when we move from
tasks that have a lot of shared
structure to tasks that are like much
more distinct
then additional challenges arise
and secondly
one of our hypotheses about why we were
seeing an optimization challenge
was this hypothesis that maybe gradients
from different tasks are conflicting in
some way
and what i mean by this is that if
they're conflicting then they're kind of
pointed in different directions
meaning that kind of one gradient wants
the model to do one thing and another
gradient wants the model to do another
thing
for two different tasks
and our second hypothesis is that in
addition to conflicting when the
gradients do conflict
they cause more damage than expected
and in particular what i mean by this is
like even if the gradients are
conflicting you should still be able to
make progress on your multi-task
objective by averaging the gradients
however there are some situations where
you won't necessarily make progress
and in particular if you have if your
objective has high curvature then the
amount of progress that you'll make may
be a bit different the amount of
progress that you think you're going to
make may be different than the amount of
progress that you actually make
so we can look at a really simple
example
uh where you have kind of this is your
parameter
um and this is your loss function so
this is like an example lost landscape
that has
a lot of curvature in the sense that
it's kind of it's not linear it's kind
of very curved
say you your your current parameter
setting is right here
and
now say that your gradient um
this is your gradient this loss function
is showing the gradient the loss
function in the gradient for one of your
tasks
now if your gradient is telling you
essentially to move
this way
so it's essentially telling you that you
should move kind of
rightward to improve
and maybe there's maybe this gradient is
really strong and there's another task
that actually wants you to go in the
opposite direction
then
if you end up kind of
ending up right here
when you have this kind of large
gradient telling you that you should go
right
then um actually
sorry i explained that a bit wrong um
let me back up a bit so
here's your current parameter update um
here's your gradient for one task
in general this gradient is telling you
that you actually want to go left
because your optimum is is to the left
and say you had another task
that was like cared very strongly about
going to the right
now
right here your gradient is kind of your
gradient for the first task for the blue
task is somewhat small and so you think
that well i'd like to go to the left but
if i go to the right it's kind of it's
not terrible but in reality when you get
this kind of second after you take the
gradient update favoring the green task
right here
then
you actually end up in a spot that's
kind of much worse than you expected
so essentially this green conflicting
gradient um caused more damage than what
your gradient was actually suggesting
that it would cause
leading to a kind of worse much worse
loss value than what your average
gradient was expecting
and then it's asking is the damage
caused by conflicts due to insufficient
model capacity
uh i think that the relationship between
model capacity and the landscape
is a bit tricky uh
in general it's like i guess it doesn't
seem like it's a model capacity issue
but model capacity can certainly play a
role
and then was asking can you explain why
it's worse
so
the reason why it's worse is that
your gradient is kind of your gradient
is just taking into account first order
information and it's not taking into
account the fact that you're that your
function is curved
and so
your gradient basically expects that if
you take a step
that is this
size that you'll end up right here
however in reality your function is
curved and so when you end up when you
actually take this step you end up in a
situation that's much worse than what
your gradient suggests
and this is something that happens
whenever you have high
positive curvature
do you have another question
yes so i just want to clarify my point
so i'm wondering so if we have a large
molar capacity i think in this high
dimensional
loss space we can find a direction where
all the gradients
are
where the final gradients that move in
the direction where
all the gradient stem
steps are taken to the right direction
yeah so it's possible this is less of an
issue when you have over parametrized
networks although uh in practice we
actually do observe
that some sort of conflict or some sort
of issue arises even with deep neural
networks
okay thank you
uh and then it's asking me this is true
even without conflicting gradients so
yeah like high curvature is kind of a
thing even if you don't have conflict
ingredients um the issue here though is
that when you do have kind of
two conflicting gradients for example
one that tells you to go in the opposite
direction
then
this is kind of more of an issue because
you end up
needing to make decisions between
different task gradients and if those
decisions are based off of your your
gradients uh then you kind of may favor
one one of the conflicting gradients
over another in a way that isn't kind of
the ideal solution
okay
um and so
kind of one solution that we can think
about to addressing this is try to avoid
when you're kind of considering multiple
gradients try to avoid making other
tasks worse when you're taking a
gradient step
and this may allow you to kind of
prevent this sort of
underestimation of how bad things will
be when gradients are conflicting
in particular the resulting algorithm is
really simple so if two gradients
conflict if their cosine similarity is
negative
then project the gradient onto the
normal plane
of the other gradient
and do it do this for both of the
gradients
and this essentially prevents the great
the kind of update from gi
from
hurting
task j
and vice versa
and if the two gradients don't conflict
then you can just leave them alone uh
and they'll have some sort of positive
transfer
and we refer to this as projecting
conflicting gradients
uh or pc grad
and what we can see is that uh
while kind of
performance of multi-task training is
typically worse than independent
training when we use this sort of
optimization technique we actually see
much better performance
than multi-task training and also better
performance than independent training
okay and then we also see performance
gains in multitask supervised learning
settings such as cfar and nyu b2 as well
okay um i was going to go a bit into
kind of a little bit more of the theory
of why it works but we're running a bit
low on time so i'm going to skip this
um
the takeaways though are kind of still
the same uh scaling to broad task
distributions is
can be quite hard and it can't
necessarily be taken for granted
training on broad and task distributions
is kind of an important step in this
direction
and it seems like there's evidence that
addressing some of the optimization
issues
that arise from these broad task
distributions can help a lot when you
are
trying to learn across these broad tasks
okay so now i want to talk a bit about
open challenges uh
and in particular we've talked a lot
already about a lot of open challenges
in multitask learning and meta learning
through the course of
this uh
over the course of this class
so what i'll talk a bit about today is
just some of the open challenges that we
haven't previously covered
in this realm
so
um
one kind of class of of challenges is
just addressing
fundamental problem assumptions in
multitask learning and meta learning
so
one area that we've talked about a bit
especially earlier today is handling out
of distribution tasks and long tail task
distributions
and the reason why this is a challenge
is that
if you have a very long tail task
distribution where different tasks
correspond to like different objects or
different driving scenarios and so forth
we know how to kind of generally do few
shot learning now and this allows us to
potentially adapt to this part of the
data distribution where we don't have a
lot of data or don't have a lot a lot of
labeled examples
but these few shot tasks in this part of
the distribution
may be
out of distribution they may be from a
different distribution than the kind of
the parts of the distribution where we
have a lot of examples
we've seen some kind of evidence that
meta-learning algorithms can allow us to
generalize to the tail
so one example that we saw early in the
class was the pro-typical clustering
networks for dermatological diseases
which allowed for kind of
some success
on long tail distributions today we also
saw adaptive risk minimization which
allows us to adapt to
to different parts of the distribution
as well
but i think that there's still kind of a
lot of work to be done here to think
about how we might handle out of
distribution tasks i think that further
hints might come from the domain
adaptation literature and the robustness
literature to think about how uh we
might adapt to things that are out of
distribution
beyond generalization
another kind of fundamental challenge is
multi-modality
so
humans for example
when we kind of leverage previous
experience our previous experience isn't
always in the form of a set of tasks
that were given
we often have kind of rich sources of
previous experiences that include visual
imagery tactile feedback
language from reading and also social
cues
and humans have this ability to kind of
kind of merge all of this rich previous
experience in a way that allows them to
build knowledge and and use that
knowledge to solve problems
and so
kind of an interesting challenge for
future algorithms is to try to learn
priors across these multiple data
modalities
this involves solving challenges such as
varying dimensionalities varying units
they also carry different and
complementary forms of information
um some hints here might come from the
literature on multimodal learning but i
think that there's still a lot of kind
of interesting challenges that come up
here
and one kind of interesting paper that
is quite recent that starts to study
this is this paper here by laying it all
learning in low resource modalities via
cross-modal generalization
and then finally
one open challenge also is
understanding when multi-task learning
will help and when and independent
training is just like the right solution
we saw one example today where
independent training is actually
sometimes actually quite a good solution
it is helpful to understand when that's
a good solution versus when
uh when different multi-test learning
techniques might be helpful for actually
allowing better transfer across tasks
beyond addressing these different
problem assumptions
one open challenges in this kind of
field is handling different
or developing and handling different
benchmarks
so ideally we want benchmarks that show
breadth that really challenge current
algorithms to find the common structure
among those tasks and leverage that to
learn more quickly
and also we want benchmarks that are
realistic that reflect
real world problems that we care about
i think that there are steps towards
some good benchmarks such as metadata
set such as the meta world benchmark i
talked about today the visual task
adaptation benchmark and the tasconomy
dataset
[Music]
and kind of a lot of these do have some
reflections of real world problems
um but ultimately we want benchmarks
that uh other benchmarks that study
problems beyond like robotic
manipulation and computer vision
that have an appropriate level of
difficulty and are also easy to use
um we also saw kind of other benchmarks
in in class so we saw kind of the land
cover classification task we saw
the kind of
the drug discovery like task where
you're predicting the activity of
different molecules
and these could also make promising
benchmarks in the field although so far
i think they were primarily introduced
as an interesting application and not
necessarily as a benchmark itself
um and then beyond kind of fundamental
problem assumptions and benchmarks uh
there's also certainly room for
improvement on improving the core
algorithms themselves
uh this includes things like computation
and memory so making like bi-level
optimization more practical
um developing more of a theoretical
understanding of the performance of
these algorithms uh there's actually
been a fair amount of work very recently
in the past year or so
that has started to develop kind of some
some interesting theoretical insights on
these algorithms but there's still a lot
more work to be done there
uh and then
also kind of another challenge
specifically in the reinforcement
learning setting
is
in not just performing lots of different
tasks but also performing tasks in
sequence where you want to kind of
compose different tasks that you've
learned into longer horizon behaviors
and then also beyond these of course
there's also the challenge that you
challenges that you discovered in your
homework and your final projects which
i'm sure there are are multiple
okay um so those are some of the
challenges that i wanted to highlight uh
before we finish i wanted to end on kind
of a bit of a broader note
and touch back a bit to some of the
things that we talked about in the very
first lecture
so
in particular if you
think about
the
biggest advances in ai and machine
learning and kind of what the biggest
milestones have been
in those areas they've been things like
td gammon or
ibm watson with jeopardy
or kind of machines that can translate
between languages
or
things that can play like atari games or
play go
and i think that all of these kind of
big milestones are examples of machines
that are actually very specialized to
solve like one
task very very well
and as a result they kind of appear very
impressive
because these are things that might be
very difficult for humans
uh so
while
impressive things may kind of imper
appear potentially very intelligent
uh
it seems like there's still things that
are missing to get to the level
of what humans are able to do
humans are kind of able to do many many
more things than what our current
machine learning and ai techniques are
able to do
and i think that like in general we've
covered a lot in cs330 to make steps
towards these kind of more generalist
systems systems that can learn multiple
tasks they can leverage previous
experience when learning new things
learning general purpose models of the
world
preparing for tasks before you even know
what they are for things like skill
discovery and unsupervised metal
learning
uh performing tasks in sequence
and also being able to kind of learn
continuously with lifelong learning
um now
what's missing uh it certainly seems
like these ingredients are things that
are helpful for us taking steps towards
more general machine learning systems
but it's likely that they aren't
this isn't kind of a the full list of
what we need to actually make kind of
really significant progress in this area
and so hopefully now that you you've
kind of learned a lot of material in
this course and that are equipped with
kind of
an overview of of all these topics
you'll have a better sense of figuring
out uh figuring out exactly what's
missing so that you can also make
progress in this area of ai research
great um that's it a couple reminders
the final projects are next week the
schedule is on piazza
um the final project report is due
at the end of next week as well
um and this is also the last lecture
uh that gives you kind of five minutes
at the end
for
to fill out course evaluations please do
fill out course evaluations um as this
is still kind of a relatively young
course you really value
your feedback
your feedback during the mid-quarter
survey was already extremely helpful and
we're planning to incorporate that into
future iterations of the course
i'd encourage you to take the time to do
course evaluations now
but i'm also happy to answer
other questions as well
beyond that
any lingering questions
so justin
thank you so much for the course so you
just skip the theoretical part of
the conflicts of the gradients can you
quickly go over that so i'm still a
little confused about
that
cool i'll spend a few minutes to go
through the theoretical part of pc grad
so
um
the first part that isn't
theoretical that's actually more
empirical is that you can take pc grad
pc grad is actually changing both the
direction and the magnitude of the
gradient and you can just kind of ablate
these two components
and what you see is that actually kind
of it seems like both of these two
components are helpful
uh
but the actually changing the direction
is more helpful than changing the
magnitude
um
but getting back to kind of what we were
talking about before
uh
it seems like there's three properties
that are
like uh that that are kind of maybe
arising in multitask learning in which
pc grad might be helping with the first
is conflicting gradients
the second is large positive curvature
and the third is having a large
difference in the magnitude of gradients
for different tasks
and if you have these three different if
these three properties kind of arise all
together which we kind of refer to as
the the tragic triad
then you could actually show that that
pc grad actually kind of
does better than just taking the average
gradient
um
one quick illustration of this is like
here's one
optimization landscape and you could
show that adam gets stuck in this
optimization landscape right here it
doesn't end up getting to the optimum
whereas atom with pc grad is able to get
to the optimum
um
but kind of more theoretically
we can show that um we can show kind of
theoretically that
if you have a large enough conflict
um curvature and a gradient magnitude
difference
that for two tasks then you can show
that pc grad is provably better than
just taking the average gradient
um i don't want to go too much into the
details but basically these three
conditions kind of translate into three
these three conditions up here
and then you can show that basically the
resulting the results of the pc grad
update leads to a better loss than the
result of the multi-task gradient
um and then we could also kind of
empirically observe that in practice
there seems to be large positive
curvature
um and there are the kind of conditions
a and b seem to also hold
most of the time
oh so can i ask a quick question
yeah
so
from my understanding then the lost
landscape
is the same
whether with or without
this pc grant
um the lost landscape does seem to be
similar with and without pc grad pc
guide really isn't changing the lost
landscape itself
uh it's changing how you apply gradients
uh to the network from this inside the
lost landscape
okay so please regret to prevent some
kind of look local optimums i i
uh
so i kind of uh
decreased the complex gradients
yeah i'm not sure if it if it's exactly
necessarily like a local optimum per se
it seems like it may actually be
something that's a bit more like
thrashing where it's kind of getting a
large grading update for one task and
then getting a large gradient update for
another task
um but yeah you can kind of think of it
something like that
yeah i see because from your last slide
you are arguing that
the item optimizer can get stuck at
extend
optimum advance optimums
so we observe that in this really simple
2d example where adam got stuck here um
it's harder to visualize like the lost
landscapes of really high dimensional
systems
so it's hard to understand exactly if
that's what's happening in the deep
neural network case but we did observe
that in this 2d example
i see thank you so much thank you for
the great course
i have a quick question i was wondering
who in
in commercial optimization non-complex
optimization we can't uh we can't
optimize crew and s also uh
are we able to do that through in in
backdrop and in machine learning
um
[Music]
so you're saying sorry in convex
optimization there's an if
and if else you know i mean so i you
decide to hear that if uh you know a dot
g i dot
gj is negative then you take the the two
the normal the normal plane
i don't know what the operation is but
you project gj onto the normal plane of
gi and vice versa and then you take that
as your variance gi and dj going forward
but i so that's that
i feel like you definitely might break
the graph into
a
hypothetical
in terms of gradient uh flow so i was
wondering if that's a minute if if the
essence looked as differentiable or how
how i know maybe i should go through the
github link or something but
if you had any ideas on how you can
implement something like that yeah so
it's straight it's quite straightforward
to implement because you don't
if it's not this isn't like a metal
learning algorithm so it's just like a
multi-test learning algorithm i mean you
don't need to differentiate through the
if and else
uh
and if you did need to differentiate
through it that would be like it would
be a bit tricky um although it might be
yeah it would be a bit tricky
um although it's kind of like
differentiating through a value which is
like sort of tricky but in reality seems
to be okay
um
yeah and the
yeah i guess maybe the other thing worth
mentioning is that you can actually show
that in the convex setting this does
actually converge to the um pc grad does
actually converge to the right answer
so it doesn't break like the convergence
property of gradient descent
okay thank you
thank you for a great course as well
great thank you everyone